en el vídeo pasado exploramos la balanza
de pagos y los tipos de pagos que pueden
fluir hacia el país o fuera del país en
particular nos enfocábamos en lo que es
la cuenta corriente la cuenta corriente
y en cosas como intercambios
importaciones pagos de ingresos ingresos
por activos en otro país ingresos por
alguien extranjero que tenga algún
negocio en el país y también vimos
transferencias transferencias netas
ahora veremos lo que es la cuenta
capital la cuenta hecho que tengo a este
demás cuentas cuenta capital y veremos
las razones son razones por las que
podrían haber ingresos o pagos en el
país en particular la cuenta capital
está enfocado en el cambio de activos en
el cambio de activos la cuenta capital
refleja un cambio neto en la propiedad
nacional de activos estamos diciendo
estamos viendo aquí información de eeuu
en año 2011 y estas delta está delta de
aquí denota cambio la delta denota
cambio así que estamos en lo que es la
cuenta corriente y aquí vamos a
enfocarnos primero antes que todo vamos
a enfocarnos en lo que son los ingresos
en las letras verdes son los ingresos
ahora aquí son los ingresos cuando yo
cuando yo no de un cambio en los activos
esto
estos son esencialmente personas fuera
de los eeuu comprando activos dentro de
eeuu entonces por ejemplo si yo soy una
constructora ciudadana americana y
construir una casa una casa preciosa la
construyó y tú dices 'wow me encanta esa
casa la quiero comprar yo digo bueno
está bien compra la tela vendo en un
millón de dólares y tú dices ok perfecto
me encanta para casa de vacaciones así
que las compras entonces por esa
transacción hay un incremento en la
propiedad de activos por esa por esa
casa de un millón de dólares que
compraste así que este número de aquí va
a aumentar e incrementará por un millón
de dólares porque deben de ir a casa y
justo por esa razón es un ingreso cuando
tú compres a casa harás un pago entonces
será un ingreso para el país ahora por
aquí tengo el cambio en la propiedad
extranjera de activos en eeuu más
derivados financieros y también aquí
tenemos lo que son las reservas
internacionales ahora veamos las
principales diferencias entre este y
este
y estoy aquí refiere refiere a la
propiedad privada de un país por
individuos que no son ciudadanos del
país mientras que este otro funciona
como un indicador económico mostrando
los recursos de los que dispone un país
para hacer las compras en el extranjero
entonces lo puedes ver como la propiedad
oficial propiedad oficial del gobierno
estoy aquí propiedad oficial del
gobierno mientras mientras que este otro
es mayormente propiedad privada ahora
entonces una vez más si un si alguien en
inglaterra y eeuu se compra una acción a
ibm y se la compra un americano entonces
este número incrementa este número de
aquí pero si el banco central de china
decide comprar un bono del gobierno de
un americano entonces este número de acá
es el que incrementaría este número de
aquí y así es como funciona esto así es
como funciona y bueno básicamente esas
son las ideas generales alguien compra
un activo hay un intercambio entre un
ciudadano americano y un ciudadano de
otro país
entonces si eso pasa estos números de
aquí
estos números de aquí incrementan
entonces éstos se incrementan ahora los
extranjeros harían un pago eeuu y los
números se incrementarían por eso por
eso recalcó estos de aquí son ingresos
son ingresos al país pero ahora ahora
veamos el otro lado de la moneda
si yo si yo saliera a comprar una casa
de vacaciones en italia se le comprará
yo a un italiano entonces yo hago el
pago y eso sería una salida de capital
americano en el cual en el intercambio
yo obtengo un activo mi casa en italia
mi casa de vacaciones en italia así que
este número de aquí incrementaría por
eso está en color naranja porque es una
salida de dinero ahora le estoy haciendo
yo un pago un extranjero entonces esto
esto es mayormente sector privado
mientras que estoy acá es reserva
federal de eeuu reserva federal de eeuu
así que si la reserva federal comprará
algún activo de algún gobierno de un
país de otro país o algún banco central
o un individuo este número d
este número incrementaría la forma en la
que yo clasifique esto el gobierno es el
que compra el gobierno acá en esta
categoría mientras que la reserva
federal
la reserva federal cae en solamente esta
categoría ahora con toda esta
información que tenemos veamos si aquí
hay déficit de cuenta capital o
superávit de cuenta capital entonces
sacar a la calculadora aquí está la
calculadora pensemos en los ingresos
aquí están los aquí están las compras
que hacen los extranjeros entonces
compraron 625 625 billones billones en
activos en activos es decir bonos bienes
raíces cosas de ese estilo
así que 625 billones más 170 165
billones 165 y eso es uno del valor de
eso nos dé el valor de 790 billones 790
millones son el cambio en activos en
compras que hacen ciudadanos extranjeros
en eeuu y luego le vamos a restar lo que
por otro lado los americanos compraron
compraron 380 billones
a los 790 y vamos a restar esa cantidad
que obtuvimos como total de ingresos le
restamos los 380 billones en salidas
para comprar activos en otros países
- menos los 16 billones que pagó la
reserva federal así que menos 16
entonces nos queda 300 94 billones
positivo o positivo esto estoy aquí es
394 millones más que estoy acá entonces
por lo tanto eeuu tuvo en el 2011
superávit de cuenta capital lo voy a
poner aquí superávit e cuenta capital de
394 billones es decir que sus ingresos
procedentes a la venta de activos bienes
tierras etcétera fueron mayores que los
pagos por compras en activos extranjeros
en efecto 394 394 billones y como puedes
ver estos números están bastante
cercanos y ahora te voy a decir algo en
futuros vídeos que se hace en tiendas el
por qué sucede esto cuando hay un poco
más de deuda pero bueno lo que te voy a
decir es que estos números deberían ser
justamente los mismos
el mismo número pero vemos que su
diferencia está en aproximadamente una
discrepancia de 80 billones lo voy a
poner aquí 80 billones 80 billones en
discrepancia que para muchos es un
número muy alto pero hablando de una
economía del tamaño de eeuu no es una
discrepancia tan enorme tan elevada
discrepancia ok ahora debemos pensar en
cómo todo esto se mide deben hacerse
estudios a muestreos deben obtenerse
información de todas partes para obtener
estos números por lo tanto es razonable
tener esta discrepancia y justo eso es
esto es una discrepancia estadística y
de hecho en teoría esto debería ser el
mismo número si tú tienes un déficit de
cuenta corriente entonces deberías tener
justo esa cantidad en el superávit de la
cuenta capital y viceversa si tuvieras
un déficit de cuenta capital entonces
tendrías un superávit en la cuenta
corriente ahora piensa por qué sucede
eso piensa lo piensa porque esto tiene
sentido esto fue una discrepancia
estadística que nos dio las oficinas de
análisis de la economía